there's a new government whistleblower
targeting the Trump administration this
time at the CDC a top scientist there
tells CBS News the agency backed away
from its fight against climate change
and even talked about using different
terminology over fears of antagonizing
the administration the whistleblower was
the head of the CDC's climate and health
program until last year when he was
reassigned mark strassman spoke to him
and is at CDC headquarters in Atlanta
mark who is this whistleblower good
morning his name is dr. George Luber and
he's worked at the CDC for 17 years the
agency made him its public face of
climate science and its effect on
diseases until the day his bosses wanted
him gone
George Luber was such a celebrated
scientist he hung out with other stars
like Matt Damon they flew around Los
Angeles in this Showtime special talking
about rising temperatures well it's a
small field but I'm one of the the
world's experts I wrote what I like to
think of as a definitive textbook on the
subject in late 2016 Luber was
organizing a CDC climate change
conference Al Gore was to be the keynote
speaker but right after Donald Trump was
elected president lubbers boss called
him in I was told the optics are not
good and that I needed to cancel it did
he explain what the optics issue was
that the meeting was happening three
weeks after the inauguration and that
the White House would be unhappy yeah
America's new president had a dim view
of Luber science Luber says his boss
wanted something else
just don't say climate change can you
call it extreme weather can you call it
something else you're saying that the
Centers for Disease Control was suddenly
afraid to use the term climate change
yeah absolutely I was told to use a
different term in March 2018 the CDC
revoked lubbers badge phone and
credentials he was escorted off the
property
the CDC moved to fire him [ __ ] face
more than 30 troubling allegations for
falsifying time cards - seeming hungover
he refuted all but one charge and was
allowed to stay but lubbers says the CDC
dismantled his climate and health
program which the agency denies the
program has not changed the program is
the same it was just placed in a
different administrative unit at the CDC
dr. Patrick pricey is lubbers boss he's
the senior manager who [ __ ] says
ordered him to scuttle the science
conference was it canceled we postponed
it you didn't feel any pressure at all
no politically no that conference
happened but without CDC sponsorship
where any CDC employees ever told stop
using that phrase climate change not to
my knowledge but we did discuss it but
you changed from climate change to
extreme weather because because climate
change was more radioactive we never
made that change we talked about
possibly making that change but we never
made the change what's unchanged brycie
insists is the CDC's commitment to
studying climate science but without its
star George Luber I asked for I see why
I can't talk about personal matters I'm
sorry mark has he been banned from the
campus so that's a personal matter that
I can't discuss is the CDC retaliating
against it it's not going to comment on
that Luber still works at the CDC but
potentially faces up to a four month
suspension he has to work from home
where he reviews scientific papers
unrelated to climate change I do not
want media attention and never did with
this and I let me let me do my work
lubbers whistleblower complaint is still
under review it also alleges the CDC
illegally misspent ten million dollars
that Congress had set aside for climate
change research the agency denies that
Tony meanwhile the science remains the
science mark thank you very much